Josh, Ben, congratulations.
You guys have made
it to the final round
of this competition.
Now we're sending
you back to your home
forge just to recreate
this iconic weapon
from history, the ram dao.
The ram-dao was a
sacrificial sword
that descends from
the weapons of India's
legendary Rajput warriors.
It's broad, heavy blade flares
to an axe-like projection,
which is ideally
suited to the ritual
beheading of large animals
such as buffalo and goats.
These sacrifices were made to
the Hindu goddess of death,
Kali, whose symbolic
eye is often
etched on the flared
end of the blade
so she can watch
over the ceremony.
The eye of Kali can be
seen on the ram-dao wielded
by Zodd in the comic
series "Berserk."
Josh, Ben, your final challenge
is to forge a ram-dao.
It must be an effective and
deadly version of the weapon
that you see here.
Just make sure that your blades
fall within the following
parameters.
The length of the blade
must be between 20
and 23 inches in length.
It must have a finial ball,
a decorative eye of Kali
a demon buffalo head as
well as a disc pommel.
Failure to meet a single
one of our parameters
is grounds for immediate
dismissal from this forge,
with no deliberation.
I feel excited
about it, because it's
something that I've
never, ever done before.
So let's do it.
You'll have four days
at your home forges
in which to complete
this challenge.
At the end of those four days,
you'll return and present
your weapons to our
panel of expert judges
and after they've
thoroughly tested them,
they'll declare one of
you the "Forged in Fire"
champion who walks out of here
with a check for 10 grand.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
First thing I'm
trying to do is
have a very, very
good visual of what
I'm going to be aiming for.
Also, we need to concentrate
on the finial right here.
That's going to be something
that I need to keep my eye on,
and it's going to
be a challenge.
So this is the piece
I'm going to be using.
It's 5160 steel.
JOSH (VOICEOVER): I've never
really have shaped something
like this before, so I feel
that the easiest way for me
to shape that curve
is just to start
using the anvil as a hammer.
And it actually worked.
First it's going great so far.
We've got the
basic profile done.
Then when it's over,
let's go have dinner.
This is mi abuelita, the
matriarch of the family.
I'm tired, and I'm ready to
stuff my face up with dinner.
[speaking spanish]
BEN: I'm back in my home forge.
It is about five
degrees right now.
Spring steel's a great material
for something like this that's
going to take a lot of
abuse and be able to flex
over and over again.
So what I'm going to try and do
first is drawing out the tang.
I'm going to do a
through tang, so it's
going to need to
be long, but also
thicker than the rest of the
blade to give it strength.
It's a big piece of
steel, but I'll cut it.
Oh, here it goes.
Boom.
The sun is setting.
It's starting to get even
colder than it already was,
so I'm about to probably
call it a night.
JOSH (VOICEOVER): All right, so
everything ready for quenching.
The heat treatment is
the soul of the knife.
This has to go well.
And I'm just noticing
a slight curve.
It's not going away.
I'm not going to lose
because of a warp.
I'm going to go
ahead and re-quench.
If it doesn't go well, a
couple of things can happen.
A big warp, or the worst
thing can be a crack.
That's going to push me
to start all over again.
Hopefully it worked.
Yeah, yeah, beautiful.
BEN: I have it hot-cut.
Now I need to add the
sweep to it, which
is going to be challenging.
I almost forgot about the
decorative finial at the top.
That's kind of one of
the things of being
a ceremonial sacrificial sword.
There's a lot of stuff on it
that's decorative that serves
no purpose other than
for religious use,
but I forget about it because
I'm used to making this stuff.
OK, the blade looks good.
I've got enough
material to work with,
so I'm going to go take it
downstairs, start grinding.
This is my homemade
belt grinder,
and this is how I have
to start this thing.
[grinding]
It's straight.
I have my bevels ground in.
It is the shape it needs to be.
I'm looking to
heat treat tonight.
Start of day four is here.
I'm going to go ahead and
start working on the handle.
Ideally what I want,
is to have a handle--
not just nice-looking,
beautiful, but also is
something that is comfortable.
So I need to have a handle
that has a grip to it,
that it doesn't feel like it's
going to fly off the hands.
I've never done a finial.
This was definitely
very challenging.
I went with a
diamond-looking piece.
It's different.
I need to really
make this blade pop,
so besides the eye in
the crown, I decide
to add extra edging to it.
But no matter how
beautiful the blade
is, if you miss one
of the parameters,
you're out of the competition.
BEN (VOICEOVER): It's day four.
There's a bit of a
warp that happened
during the tempering
of the spine,
and I don't have enough
time to re-quench.
I have too much
other stuff to do,
but I can still make
this blade look the part.
I can still make it perform
really, really, well,
so that's my goal for today.
[grinding]
[hammering]
I'm just getting to
work on the finial.
It doesn't have to look
like anything in particular,
it's just kind of
a knob at the end.
I don't do a whole
lot of engraving,
so this is kind of out
of my comfort zone.
But after some light sanding,
it's going to be done.
So I'm ready to
go cut something.
Whoo.
That's sharp.
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the kill test.
Ram-dao, ram carcass.
Josh, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Well, let's kill it again.
Doug is holding my ram-dao
and I'm just thinking,
just chop the head off.
Just chop it.
My heart is just pumping
10,000 miles per hour, man.
[music playing]
Oh, my god.
[slashing]
[laughs]
All right, Josh, let's
talk about your ram-dao here.
The blade you have
here is sharp.
For every pass it
makes, it cuts deeply.
But I also love what you
have in the sense of balance.
That even though it's
a chopper, the recovery
is just comfortable
enough to where you
can cut all the way through.
It feels good in the hand.
It's got a great balance, and
most importantly, it will kill.
Good job.
That's awesome.
Thank you.
All right, Ben,
it's your turn.
You ready for this?
I'm excited.
Let's do it.
BEN: Right now,
I'm really excited.
I've put my best work into this.
Nothing's perfect,
but my biggest concern
is that there was a
slight warp that I
just really couldn't get out.
So I'm really hoping
that my blade outperforms
Josh's in every other
way so that it's
a flaw can be overlooked.
Something's off
about this design.
There's a bit of an issue.
BEN (VOICEOVER): At this
point, I'm a bit confused.
I don't know what's going on.
Ben, your blade doesn't
have a finial bowl.
One of the defining
characteristics of the ram-dao.
It was also one
of the parameters,
and the judges feel that
your blade cannot be tested
evenly and fairly with Josh's.
Dave Baker is going
to tell you why.
The design of the
ram-dao has that
finial at the end of a blade.
That finial can wind up
being a cut restrictor,
not allowing the blade
to pass through a target.
It also keeps that blade
from being able to stab.
Yours doesn't have that.
How can we test them evenly?
BEN: I understand.
Ben, "Forged in
Fire" champions
don't miss parameters.
I'd like to invite you
to shake our hands,
shake your competitor's
hand, and then
please leave the forge.
I'm pretty disappointed.
I really wanted to see my
blade chop through that ram.
But I'm happy with what I turned
in, and at the end of the day,
I think I'm definitely
leaving a better
bladesmith than when I came in.
Josh, congratulations.
You're the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Come on forward and
shake our hands, brother.
I cannot believe
this is happening.
I think what I'm going to do
with the $10,000 is going to go
to open a shop where I'm
going to be providing
workshops for at-risk youth.
My abuelita told me
go, win, and come back.
Mission accomplished.
[music playing]